[Musica]
chi è il vero francesco chi è la vera
società
chi sono chi siamo noi chi siete voi
questa è la domanda davvero che continua
rear ariston armi dentro sempre sempre
sempre e arrivo da una terra da una
valle dalla valtellina da lì ho guardato
la natura tutti noi abbiamo sempre la
tour attorno e natura ci può ispirare ho
cominciato a cercare di chiedermi anche
chi è una vera pianta di mele chi è e
cosa fa una pianta di mele cosa produce
una pianta di mele e la cosa
interessante è che ho colpito da una
pianta di miele produce mele da un punto
di vista umano
però ho anche visto che se la pianta di
mele guarda la vera essenza della pianta
di mele la pianta di mele fa anche
un'operazione che cosa di assorbire
anidride carbonica per poi rilasciare
ossigeno a questo punto è chi è la vera
pianta di mele è solo colei che da delle
mele oppure è colei che fa anche questa
operazione di assorbire per rilasciare
ossigeno che sono quindi veramente io
sono qualcuno che lavora secondo degli
schemi sociali oppure sono qualcuno che
fa anche qualcosa di più
al che ho cominciato a ragionare su
quelli che sono gli schemi sociali e ho
cominciato a scoprire una cosa per me
super interessante ho cominciato a
vedere che il mondo è pieno di regole
rotte delle regole sociali rotte delle
regole di cooperazione rotte
ho cominciato a pensare quindi che le
regole rotte dovevano essere rotte
quindi ho cominciato a mettermi come
mantra mio il fatto di rompere le regole
che erano rotte e quindi la pianta di
mele non solo produrre miele ma anche
produrre ossigeno di watt e nessuno ha
istruito la pianta di mere per produrre
ossigeno lo fa da sola quindi pianto di
miele sa veramente chiara vera pianta di
mele io
insomma ci sto un po pensando no su chi
è il vero francesco nella vita ognuno di
noi si fa un po i conti su cui
che gli succede chi va a fare un lavoro
piuttosto che un altro piuttosto che un
altro e io mi sono trovato in qualche
modo a capire cercare a condurre
l'azienda fondare aziende condurre
aziende mi sono trovato sempre in
qualche modo ad essere diciamo a capo di
qualcosa e da lì ho detto ma qual è il
vero senso di quello che facciamo dove
chi siamo noi
e guardando le montagne ho cominciato a
pensare mi son visto come quello che
raccoglieva cuore a un certo punto che è
l'ossigeno che viene prodotto e
guardando le montagne della mia cara
carissima valle ho cominciato a dire ma
guardando la cima la cima è un po il
posto di questa montagna in cui io
voglio andare su è un po come se fosse
la mia
il mio obiettivo se vi chiedete un
alpinista che cosa vuole fare nella vita
vuole andare in cima alle montagne per
scendere ea questo punto nelle
organizzazioni o vi ho detto cavolo
quale l'organizzazione qual è la cima
della nostra organizzazione
chi siamo veramente noi perché siamo un
ottima organizzazione che produce delle
ottime mele non facciamo bene però
facciamo produciamo delle 8 ottimi
servizi ottimi prodotti il mercato ci
riconosce che siamo molto bravi ma qual
è il nostro vero proposito chi siamo noi
veramente e che cosa è l'organizzazione
veramente e da lì abbiamo cominciato a
darci collegi collettivamente delle
risposte e quindi abbiamo cominciato a
capire che a darci un senso a dare il
senso all'organizzazione all'azienda
nella quale tutti noi lavoravamo come vi
piace di più pensare all'azienda nella
quale tutti noi serviamo noi siamo servi
del nostro vero essere perché noi non
pensiamo a volete pensare che cos'è il
futuro tanti mi dicono che dovremmo
lasciare un futuro migliore dobbiamo
lasciare un futuro migliore a una
domanda secondo me no secondo me
dobbiamo lasciare un presente migliore
perché se ci pensate bene tutti noi qua
oggi siamo io sono in piedi su questo
punto rosso voi siete seduti e ci
troviamo in una condizione in cui
qualcuno domani si richiederà o
ritornerai
quindi su questo palco e come se io in
questo momento stessi già frequentando
il futuro di qualcun altro ma non io
devo pensare al suo futuro e quindi
proiettarmi da quella parte oppure devo
pensare che questo punto rosso e la
vostra sedia in qualche modo deve essere
preservata deve essere vissuta bene e
quindi deve essere lasciata perché
quello è già un futuro in prestito che
avete da qualcun altro
allora se io comincio a pensare che in
prestito da qualcun altro
comincio a capire che come qualsiasi
prestito che io tengo vado da una banca
a chiedere dei soldi in prestito li devo
ridare indietro quindi questo qualcun
altro che arriverà dal futuro mi darà
dovrà riconsegnarlo il suo futuro perché
c'è un prestito a una banca generalmente
mi chiede degli interessi attivi e
quindi dovrò dare indietro anche degli
interessi attivi
è questo il senso di quello che devo
fare quindi non devo costruire un futuro
migliore ma devo costruire un mio
presente migliore è solo con
quell'azione lille che riconsegna il
futuro di chi verrà dopo di me su questo
palco di chi verrà dopo di voi su quelle
sedie e chi verrà dopo di noi è davvero
sistemico è sempre un discorso più
grande di chi arriverà dopo di noi per
trovare il mondo se ci pensate ci sono
grandi artisti
pensiamo al david di michelangelo sono
opere d'arte che riescono a resistere
centinaia di anni e quindi riescono a
prendere hanno preso in prestito tutto
il futuro lo sanno riconsegnando la
magnificenza dell'arte
ora pensate come cambia il sistema se
un'azienda comincia a ragionare con
questo termine che imprese da un futuro
pensate la relazione che c'è con un
cliente il cliente consegnate solo delle
mele al cliente consegnate anche
l'impatto che andrete a produrre per
costruire a quelle mele i clienti ti
scelgono anche per quel motivo
chiaramente dove dovete saper fare delle
mele buone al mercato attuale e quindi
non potete far spendere dieci volte
tanto per le mele ma pensate l'azienda
l'azienda sta servendo l'azienda e semi
clienti stanno servendo in proposito
evolutivo e quindi cosa fa questa
organizzazione questa organizzazione sa
perché lavoro
l'organizzazione diventa una piattaforma
nelle quali le persone si possono
sviluppare evolvere possono trovare se
stessi
questo è il senso di un'organizzazione
quindi ha senso avere una gerarchia
all'interno dell'organizzazione ha senso
di avere qualcuno che ti dice cosa tu
devi fare
no lo sai già perché tu sai che vuoi
trasformare co2 in ossigeno producendo
bene tu sai questo quindi tu sai che ti
devi muovere in quella direzione perché
costruirai un impatto sul futuro che ti
è stato dato in prestito quindi
un'azienda può essere autorganizzata
un'azienda può essere un organismo
vivente che continua giorno per giorno
ad apprendere ed imparare questo il
senso di quello che sta succedendo
questo è il senso di come se io riesco a
capire chi sono veramente se io riesco a
capire chi siamo veramente riesco a fare
e da lì chiaramente c'è il consiglio
amministrazione di un'azienda e che tipo
di leadership deve avere un consiglio
pensa te e tutto da quella montagna
stiamo scendendo da quella mia montagna
della mia cara valle scendo un
amministratore delegato è a servizio del
proposito evolutivo dell'azienda non è
il capo il campo il proposito è quello
che noi tutti vogliamo fare e tutto il
resto va al servizio di questo proposito
si parla di serva alla leadership e così
anche il capitale in italia siamo
fortunati perché abbiamo le società
benefit che sono uno strumento che ci
permette di fare questo abbiamo la
certificazione di corpi eccetera
eccetera
il punto vero è che le aziende diventano
dei posti delle piattaforme in cui le
persone si possono risvegliare in cui le
persone possono trovare se stesse in cui
le persone danno un senso al lavoro
oltre il compenso il panero paghiamo
quindi il compenso è ragionevole e
normale che una pianta di mele produca
mele non mettiamolo in discussione ma il
punto importante è che dobbiamo
cominciare a capire che noi impattiamo
nella società perché abbiamo in futuro
in prestito da qualcuno
quindi le funzioni sono tutte le
funzioni di un'organizzazione
tradizionale sono all'interno di tutti
io sono un po ecc a richard ufficio del
personale
io sono un po sì e fu finanziario io
sono un po di tutte le parti è chiaro se
tutti noi stiamo servendo un proposito
posso condividere con voi tutte le
informazioni di questo per quest era
arrivare a questo proposito i salari
possono essere trasparenti
il bilancio mensile può essere
trasparente il budget può essere a
disposizione di tutti di tutti quelli
che attraverso l'azienda vogliono
cambiare il mondo
pensate se hr se l'ufficio del personale
all'interno di ognuno di noi che assume
le persone in un'azienda che serve un
proposito ma fa mele
ricordiamocelo fa mele se io sono in
quella condizione io cosa voglio io
voglio che le persone in sé chi volesse
assumere qualcuno che deve lavorare con
me voglio che quella persona sfrutti
l'azienda come il luogo in cui quella
persona si può sviluppare quindi
chiederei a questa persona come prima
cosa so che tu sai gestire le mele so
che tu sai potare ma voglio anche capire
se tu vuoi veramente venire a sviluppare
te stesso e di qua un piccolo pensiero
perché quando si pensa in maniera
imprenditoriale
si comincia a ragionare e comincia a
pensare a che cos'è files che l'ing
un'azienda deve poter scalare anche
l'impatto che produce un'azienda deve
poter scalare deve poter andare e
diventare esponenziale su tutto questo
movimento delle exponential organisation
che dice dobbiamo fare cose e la parte
importante che vi voglio dire
pensate che dobbiamo trovare un sistema
e dobbiamo continuare a rompere delle
regole che sono già road pensate quando
andate a trattare e con una con un
un procurement un ufficio acquisti
andato a trattare l'ufficio acquisti la
prima cosa che vi chiede uno sconto e
dice io con voi però voglio avere una
relazione a lungo periodo e come se io
incontrassi una bellissima ragazza la
guardo di quiete ti voglio sposare ma
pozzi e quindi la relazione è strana
perché io ti voglio sposare ma insomma
c'è un problema da fissare
ma siamo la reazione a lungo termine non
voglio dire stiamo già trovando una
situazione
questo è quello che succede normalmente
io vado da ufficio acquisti e l'ufficio
questo e mi dice sempre a guarda noi
volevamo capiamo la tua fornitura alle
tue e mail eccetera eccetera però
insomma i tuoi soldi che mi chiedi che
erano 100 saranno 80 perché per noi è
tanto io da lì ho cominciato a pensare a
cavoli e dura questa cosa qua come se io
volessi stabilire veramente una
relazione a lungo termine ma non riesco
allora la parte che che ho cominciato a
ragionare pensando mi parte di un
sistema tutti noi siamo parte di un
sistema tutti noi facciamo parte di un
sistema e se siamo parte del sistema
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare che in
maniera mutualistica dobbiamo aiutare
l'altra parte a far che cosa a fidarsi
del sistema è diverso anche del mia
parte anch'io a fidarmi nell'altra parte
quindi arrivare a concepire che l'altra
parte ha ragione quindi la sua
quantificazione giusta quindi
il punto è ci sono 2 2 pesi 2
sedimentarie della t shirt per lo stesso
corpo chi di voi non ha due magliette di
taglie diverse però che che calzano lo
stesso corpo
ognuno di noi cioè le sa perché è perché
sono due pesi e due taglie due pesi per
lo stesso corte allora la parte la parte
importante realizzando questo allora
anche il nostro cliente ha ragione
quindi la sua valutazione è la sua
valutazione la sua percezione di valore
a super interessa
anche questo argomento se comincio a
pensarlo e dico lo sconto di per sé era
una regola che era rotta perché è
normale chiedere lo sconto ma perché è
normale nessuno lo sa chiedere è rotto
il punto importante però è che quello
sconto lì a un punto sul quale io posso
ragionare è un punto sul quale io
assieme al cliente posso fare un
ragionamento in più perché ricordiamoci
io voglio espandere l'impatto il bene
che io voglio produrre rispetto al mio
proposito rispetto alla cima della mia
montagna
cosa posso fare posso trasformare questo
concetto di differenza di prezzo e
costruirla come se fosse una scommessa
quando vado al casinò e faccio una
scommessa pensando di vincere tutto e
quindi pensando di prendere questa
scommessa questi soldi di differenza di
noi li vogliamo scommettere per il
nostro proposito evolutivo perché
vogliamo amplificare il chi siamo noi se
ci pensate su un partito da quando avevo
13 anni a chiedermi chi sono io
veramente poi all'interno delle
organizzazioni in cui ho vissuto a con i
miei colleghi ho sempre detto che siamo
noi veramente a questo punto con con il
cliente anche i fornitori e tutti i
portatori di interesse ho chiesto ma noi
chi siamo veramente che siamo ancora di
più qual è il senso del nostro lavoro
perché dobbiamo lavorare assieme perché
io ti devo fornire le mele e la cosa
interessante che ragionando in questi
termini anche corpo ed grandissime
capiscono e dicono ah vero stiamo
facendo qualcosa di importante quindi
puntiamo questi soldi come se fosse una
scommessa e dichiariamo una
interdipendenza tra le due parti quindi
di caliamo che queste due parti sono tre
di loro interdipendenti per costruire o
per riconsegnare un futuro qualcuno che
aveva per quello che vi dicevo e quindi
il punto importante è riuscire a
stabilire rispetto a delle una lingua
comprensibile e siamo nel 2019 ce
l'abbiamo abbiamo liegi
siamo di sdg walk on his al gol con i
target abbiamo il mondo delle benefit
corporation
abbiamo lega l'ente una su una struttura
legale srl sbs psb che mi permette di
dire che io posso seguire un proposito
evolutivo di chiariamoci per come noi
vogliamo lasciare impatto nel mondo e
andiamo un esempio potremmo commissioen
arci con un cliente e magari
un'assicurazione una banca e dire guarda
io credo che tu produci tanta carta per
i tuoi elaborati
facciamo così prova a ridurla se tu la
riduce io questa cifra da scommetto
assieme te sul fatto che tu riuscirai a
ridurre carta ridurre carta per la
maggior parte delle volte oggi vuol dire
tagliare alberi vuol dire impattare a
non li vedo chiaramente gli alberi qua
però se penso questo futuro che devo
riconsegnare magari un giorno li vedrò
anch'io quegli alberi che avrò segato
pensate che cosa interessante se poi ci
aggiungo anche l'ingrediente legale e
quindi caro carlo cliente o caro
fornitore possa fare la stessa cosa
anche con un fornitore sul fornitore
posso andare a creare una a chiedere di
rendere le sue persone più felici
la felicità si misura si chiama
psicometria quindi io posso fare delle
serve settimanali per misurare la
felicità e posso andare a mettere queste
cause le questi sconti si chiamano
sconti incondizionati una regola rotta
lo sconto condizionatori bates e posso
andare a mettere questo scontro
condizionato che dice guarda caro
cliente caro fornitore se non si applica
se tu non fai azioni in cui le tue
persone sono più felici in cui tuta gli
indugi meno carta e perché ti mando i
file via pdf
io ti devo chiedere indietro quei soldi
perché la scommessa l'abbiamo persa
e cosa farà la di quei soldi in maniera
assolutamente trasparente perché tutti
stiamo servendo in proposito li userò
per ricolmare per ridare indietro quello
che stiamo privando come futuro di chi
viene
questo lo chiamiamo accordo
interdipendenza in cui tutti assieme
riconosciamo tramite un contratto che
siamo partiti
sistema con questo quello che voglio
dirvi è che con le nostre azioni
se continuiamo a vivere seguendo le
regole e non cerchiamo di mettere in
discussione certe volte delle regole non
dico di violarle ma dico semplicemente
di rielaborarle di digerirle abbiamo un
grandissimo lo stomaco e un grandissimo
apparato digerente possiamo veramente
essere dei grandi digestato ri sennò non
cominciamo a vedere queste regole
se noi non cominciamo a capire che
impatto e scalare l'impatto che noi
produciamo noi non faremo qualcosa di
efficace per il futuro e l'ultimo
messaggio che vi voglio lasciare che
ognuno di noi con le sue azioni produce
impatto e disegna nella sua vita
l'impatto può essere positivo neutro o
per me neutralizzante è negativo sanno
che la scelta per ogni volta io da un pò
nel momento che mette un piede avanti
produco quell'impatto trovando solo noi
stessi trovando solo il modo con il
quale noi agiamo possiamo dipingere il
mondo che vorremmo tutti noi stiamo
dipingendo la mastella
[Applauso]